as many people know apple and epic games
have been at war with each other epic
games went and sued apple in federal
court and said that they had a monopoly
on the app store and they took 30
which was the equivalent of almost 20
billion dollars in in-app purchases
a federal judge
20 minutes ago just handed down
part of a ruling it's a permanent
injunction in the epic verse apple case
under the new order apple is permanently
restrained and enjoined from prohibiting
developers from including in their apps
and their metadata buttons external
links or other calls to action that
direct customers to purchasing
mechanisms in addition to in-app
purchasing and communicating with
customers through points of contact
obtained voluntarily from customers
through account registration within the
app
uh-oh
bang bang apple
just got
hit hard
what this means is that
the court cannot ultimately is a quote
from the judge the court cannot
ultimately conclude that apple is a
monopolistic under either federal or
state antitrust laws nonetheless the
trial did show that apple is engaging in
anti-competitive conduct under
california's competition laws so the
fact that apple will not allow epic
games or anyone else to have other
options for in-app purchases and it can
only use apple's in-app purchase
technology
means that apple was being
anti-competitive and therefore
the judge has ruled that apple cannot do
that anymore epic games looks like they
are likely to win from a spirit of what
they were trying to accomplish saying
that apple should not be able to force
us to use their technology for in-app
purchases we should be able to have our
own in-app purchase technology we should
be able to communicate with our
customers without apple stepping in the
way
with that said it looks like epic games
is going to have to pay some money
though
for damages that have been caused as
well
and so when you see
the apple situation
you also see that google is being sued
by epic games over its own effort to
maintain the google play store as the
central source of software on android
absolutely fascinating to watch as we go
to court
and apple which has
constantly hid behind the fact that
everyone pays 30 no one gets a special
deal
we have found out that might not be true
but also now we are finding that a judge
says they are being anti-competitive and
likely to force apple to drastically
open this up which immediately comes to
mind for me is bitcoin the whole web 3
world etc if now all of a sudden apple
products you can pay for things in
bitcoin for example and you don't have
to go through the app stores in
app payment system and we don't have to
wait for apple to adopt bitcoin but
instead others can say hey you can just
use the bitcoin rails right within the
app store it's a pretty big deal apple
down two and a half percent on the news
should be down more it should be down
more it's gonna i feel like it will go
down people are just not financial
advice people are just processing it now
yeah
um all right this isn't this that that's
not really like that surprising to me
though like apple does have a monopoly
and the fact that if you download an app
through the app store you still pay them
a percentage on in-app purchases is
ridiculous i agree
do we do you remember that really fire
like video that epic epic games put out
um in the beginning against apple do you
remember
anthony's not paying attention this is
what happens
this is what happens ladies and
gentlemen what is that the video
the video that
that epic games put out oh the 1984 they
did a play on the apple 1984 uh video
yeah i mean look it it uh it was a great
point in terms of them being able to uh
take the stance that apple has had for
decades of we're the upstart we're the
challenger we're the person you know
that's for the creators etc and they
basically said cool are you
well how about this why don't we just
flip it on you and show how you've
actually become the man people know i
say this all the time if you live long
enough in business
as a startup you eventually become the
man you become the incumbent and so bill
gates one at one point was like the
shadowy supercoder who was in the
basement and he was you know trying to
take down ibm
now bill gates is a multi-billionaire
and everyone you know half the world
thinks he's evil and the other half of
the world thinks that he's you know
intelligent like
literally 50 years ago 40 years ago he
was a shadowy supercoder
same thing with steve jobs and apple
they literally had the home brew
computer uh club right they were sitting
there they were doing they created the
1984 commercial like all stuff
now they're getting sued by epic games
being like you're the incumbent you're
being anti-competitive like all this
type of stuff it's
it's almost like it's a tale as old as
time but uh
it's just different players
do you think that one day the best
business show is going to be like people
are going to be angry at it and there's
going to be the the new best business
show
no apple apple just released their
release date or just announced their
release date for their new iphone
absolutely ridiculous my iphone's about
starts slowing down yeah
everyone knows how that goes if you have
an older iphone get ready don't update
your software it will start slowing down
um
i think that they admitted this
i'm pretty sure that they admitted this
uh
well to be honest if it's fearful what
if tesla starts doing that to their cars
you have an older version of a tesla you
know what it actually doesn't go as far
as it used to not because of the battery
because we said so and thanks for
updating your software
in july of this year uh
the iphone um they were accused again of
artificial slowdowns of the iphone with
worn out batteries
initially apple denied the accusations
but after a series of independent
research and widespread publicity it was
forced to admit guilt
as a result the company had to pay a lot
of money to the victims same situation
began to be forgotten the company
stopped slowing down the iphone and
returned that topic less and less but
new claims have appeared against apple
and they again relate to the force slow
down to smartphones moreover the company
is slowing down newer models including
the iphone 12 according to the new
accusations the consumer protection
society in spain said that there is
reason to believe that apple continues
to artificially slide on smartphones and
we were talking about such models as the
really really new ones so uh they've
admitted in the past that they had that
they did it uh they had reasons for
doing it uh but it only came after there
was multiple research reports that were
published that said
you can't tell if you're not doing it
like it's happening uh defend yourself
so i probably think that you're more
right than wrong john in that uh that
we're likely to see
a lot of slowing down a lot
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're going to build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help
[Music]